okay third question in the marvel film
avengers end game what does your
character say after he takes the
infinity stones from thanos and thanos
realize he has no power can i guess
well that's over
uh correct answer is uh i am iron man
that is good but
i had so many alt lines that i wanted to
give forward give us oh yeah
oh god let me think uh they were all
super smart ash lines like i i was
trying to you know dumb stuff like you
are so
[ __ ] or whatever
you know what i'll have to go back to my
notes what was the thing he took
robert's character took the the what i
get the infinity stones and then have
the power right to snap and have
whatever i want to happen oh i was going
to say oh snap
why not
i'll tell you why it was too smart ass
and it was the whole arc of a character
and it was uh i think
maybe one of our great editors idea or
one of the writers to say we need to go
right back to the first film and have
him his dying words be the words of his
origin i see you know we love a bookend
please subscribe i am doing this every
day uh i'll see you guys tomorrow thanks